I'm a big fan of the concept of
curiosity I wake up in the morning and
ask myself what can I do today that will
awaken in me a ravenous sense of wonder
of wonderment now what is wonderment
wonderment is when the world bewitches
you when the world in trances you when
the world arrests your attention Charles
Darwin actually talked about this back
in the day about the the power of
attention how attention how our capacity
to focus to become enchanted by
something it was a necessary precursor
for any kind of interpersonal experience
that is transformative that is
educational right we need to be focused
we need to be paying attention looking
begins with love love begins with
looking right and that is a prerequisite
for transformation and so wonder
requires attention now attention if
we're lucky enough to get it attention
when sudden and when close as Darwin
used to say we'll then graduate into
sort of a sense of surprise you know
attention a sudden and close graduates
and surprise and this then graduates to
the next stage astonishment take a
breath
right you're inspired you know the
moments to take your breath away and
then then astonishment will graduate to
the next level which is just stupefied
amazement right cognitive ecstasy that
sense of first sight unencumbered by
knowingness when you have no mental
models no references for what you're
seeing and it's just coming in and you
are in the living breathing act of
accommodating yourself to what's
happening you're letting it all in
without your film screen of defense
mechanisms and filters and prejudices
and all these things that get in the way
of experiencing that thing freshly and
intensely you know I've talked about the
power of awe to be so decentering it's
been described as an experience of OPA
de de Jason see you're sort of blissed
out of your own way and in turn
something significant it can actually
happen you can finally be shaken to
tears you can finally be moved
to the point of tears and we love this
right cascading waves of cognitive
ecstasy a sort of neurological neuro
storm of intense intellectual pleasure
Carl Sagan was right he said
understanding is a kind of ecstasy right
there is an ecstasy of understanding
there's a sense of Revelation a sense
that the cloud parts the curtain parts
and what had never been seen as being
devoured by the eyes even a blade of
grass right even a blade of grass we've
been told by the Romantic poets when
seeing through a microscope when given
complete attention becomes a magnificent
universe in itself radiant and alive and
exploding with wonderment so if only we
could do that if only we could hijack
our perceptual apparatus and see the
world as if through a microscope as if
through a telescope as if through
time-lapse photography right we can hack
space perception time and mind we can
literally instrument ourselves into
blissful states of rapturous ah that in
turn my friends and this is where it
serves as existential medicine in turn
these experiences right of
contemplating space and time on a scale
just shy of the infinite leave us with
real lasting cognitive benefits we get
increased creativity increased
well-being increased compassion we are
more than what we owe that what we were
these experiences add up to being more
than the sum of their parts there is
transcendence there is something new
being born in astonishment and so what
we have to do is be willing to go there
be willing to go there be willing to go
there
you